nick is with us in Kansas City hi Nick
how are you hi thank you so much for
taking my call
certainly how can we help so I'm in baby
step three right now and honestly I feel
like I'm having a hard time committing
to it so if I can give a quick
explanation basically I'm I feel like
I'm at a job I don't really like and I
kind of want to quit and that's why I
feel like I'm not really so committed
you know I mean well having an emergency
fund for your family is a different
thing to be committed to than having a
job that you hate there are two
different things
I don't quite understand well the
emergency fund is taking care of your
family and taking care of stabilizing
your household your career choice is a
completely different thing from an
emergency fund I hate my job I mean you
could change your job tomorrow whether
you had an emergency fund or not as long
as you made the same amount of money or
more okay I don't know I'm trying to
blank with what you're saying I
apologize that's okay that's okay
there are two separate issues your
emergency fund should not your
motivation to do an emergency fund
should not be affected by the fact that
you hate your job looking looking for a
new job should be affected by that
changing careers should be affected by
that that may or may not entail you need
some money to do all of that but you
need an emergency fund to protect your
family regardless of what career you
have it's a second it's a separate issue
and so the motivation to do them both is
a separate motivation it's a separate
reasoning so I think you need to work on
both I think you do need to talk about
changing careers what do you do for a
living I'm here okay I am what do you
want - well my ultimate dream is to
develop video games and start a business
on my own to do that I mean I do it as a
hobby just on the side I'm trying to you
know essentially build that outside
business where I'm making a site income
and all mm-hmm
well there's a lot of open open doors to
contracting and side gig hustle in that
world tons and tons you could do and you
could make extra money all with the
motivation of not only first getting my
emergency fund in place but then also
get some an additional you know war
chest aside to be able to start my own
gig but what if you got enough gaming
side gigs going then it almost equals
your regular income well I mean if I was
making enough from just the side gigs
and I'd probably just go ahead and quit
my job there you go and if you're and if
you didn't well what do you make now
that's your job
79 K okay and so what if you were at 50
K instead of 80 K with side hustles but
in addition to your emergency fund you
had 30 K banked as a war chest one year
to cover the difference then you could
quit your job too right I mean yeah I
definitely live off of that there's no
problem
yeah so the point the point is finishing
the emergency fund and building the side
gig hustle as big as you can build it as
fast as you can build it are those two
are tied together because we need more
than an emergency fund to be able to
just quit or we need to have replace the
income with side hustle or some
combination of those two things does
that all make sense yeah so now I get
you know so much side gig as you can get
and work your tail end off get crazy for
a short period of time and you know and
the good news is in your world you can
make a lot of money in a short period of
time you could you should be able to
double your household income in 12 to 18
months I just got a map it out you know
exactly you got to go get then you gotta
go get the gigs now you got to go get
somebody to work side deals for right
yeah that's not in any kind of violation
with your current employer you don't
want to have any ethics issues or legal
issues or anything like that but um hang
on I'm gonna send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
which is a wonderful book about building
a career that you love and this will
show you exactly how to do that the
proven strategy that will lead to the
career you love and its number one
bestseller will send it out to you our
gift hang on man open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
[Music]
what I didn't ask him about and I goofed
was I shoulda asked him and confirmed my
suspicions that he's never had a big
emergency cuz usually if you've had a
big emergency or two smack you around
life has punched your teeth out a couple
times you really see the value for the
emergency fund much more than if you've
never had those down times that's my
guess it's not it's not a problem it's
just a you thing he's looking for
motivation it's a good good discussion
thanks for calling me